هذا ما تأمل روسيا أن يكون
اللقاح
الذي يتغلب على الوباء العالمي الذي حصلنا
عليه من بداية المرحلة
الثالثة من التجارب الحاسمة
والمتطوعين مثل أندريه لاكتشاف
ما إذا كان سبوتنيك v كما يطلق عليه
حقًا يمكن أن ينقذ الأرواح التي
كنت أبحث عنها  إلى الأمام إلى هذه
المرحلة الثالثة من التجارب ،
أريد أن ينتشر هذا اللقاح على نطاق واسع في
أقرب وقت ممكن
حتى يكون جميع مواطني بلدنا الكبير
آمنين.
من الدول
الأشد تضرراً في العالم لكن
موسكو اتهمت بقطع
الزوايا
باستخدام الجواسيس لسرقة الأبحاث الغربية
وهو ما
تنفيه وبعد نتائج إيجابية مبكرة
بالموافقة على لقاحها
حتى قبل بدء تجارب المرحلة الثالثة
ما يمكننا قوله هو أن هذا اللقاح الروسي الجديد
أه ال  النتائج مشجعة ولكن
من السابق لأوانه أو
السابق
لأوانه الاعتقاد بأن هذا هو الأساس
للقاح ناجح
للاستخدام العام  ولكن في مستشفى المدينة
رقم 2 في موسكو
حيث شاهدنا أول
40000 متطوع تجريبي تم حقنهم ،
أخبرني الأطباء أنهم متفائلون بأن
هذه
التجارب المهمة ستساعد في إنشاء
اللقاح الروسي
ولهذا السبب تقول معلمة مدرسة الحضانة ياكاتارينا
إنها تطوعت  شارك
على الرغم من المخاطر
، من الضروري أن تخبرني ليس فقط لنفسها
ولكن لأي شخص آخر